Game of Thrones fans may be committed to memorizing
every pivotal show scene, absorbing all of
George R.R. Martin's book details, and reading
endless theories online, but there's one thing
about the show we might never get to experience:
the original pilot.
Thanks to the cast shake-ups that occurred
after the first version of this worldbuilding
premiere was filmed in 2008, we already knew
that this unaired pilot existed somewhere,
collecting dust and largely regarded with
disdain by its creators.
The series started out with Tamzin Merchant
in the role of Daenerys Targaryen, Jennifer
Ehle as Catelyn Stark, and Jamie Campbell
Bower as Night's Watchman Waymar Royce, but
it wasn't the acting that the showrunners
took issue with.
There were also some points of plot confusion
that rendered the first take a failure, like
the fact that it wasn't clear Jaime and Cersei
Lannister were siblings.
Weiss said of the first production, "Watching
[screenwriter Craig Mazin and others] watch
that original pilot was one of the most painful
experiences of my life."
Benioff agreed, adding, "I was taking notes,
and I had this yellow legal pad, and I just
remembered writing in all caps, ‘MASSIVE
PROBLEM,’ and it’s all I could think about
the rest of the night."
As a result, they decided to shelve almost
all of the footage and re-shoot the opening
episode, which turned out to be a major success,
and courted millions of fans right away.
The unseen footage, it seems, might never
see the light of day.
Kit Harington, who of course portrays Jon
Snow, our resident King in the North, has
also recently weighed in on the abandoned
premiere effort, telling The Guardian, "They
made a lot of mistakes.
It didn't look right, didn't feel right, had
nothing different about it."
Like the rest of us, he's never seen it in
full but indicated his 2008 Jon Snow was clean-shaven,
with his long locks being a simple wig.
Nevertheless, the network didn't give up after
one poor pass.
"HBO decided to pick up the series despite
all of the problems with the pilot, we got
the chance to go back and re-write it."
When the team reassembled for a second try
at the show, they leaned more heavily into
the adult content of the series, making it
dirtier, sexier, bloodier, and more tangibly
real.
Suddenly, a story that came off as hokey on
the first try became arresting to watch on
screen.
None of this was instantly alarming to Harington,
who had the good fortune of landing Jon Snow
as his first onscreen role.
He said, "We didn't know if it was going to
go, and we didn't know if it was going to
be any good.
But it was HBO, and it was American TV, so
it felt like a huge deal."
Even though he wasn't part of the original
screening-gone-so-wrong, he has seen bits
and pieces of the original take because Weiss
and Benioff have used it before as blackmail
material, sending him unflattering screenshots
from the episode and threatening the release
of the amateurish first work to keep him in
line.
He said, "They say, if I ever piss them off
too much, they'll release it on YouTube.
Every now and then, they send me a screengrab,
just as a threat."
Given its rocky start, Game of Thrones feels
more and more like a miracle to have achieved
such a large scale and dedicated audience
investment.
But the idea that there exists an episode
of the show from the same creative team that
misses the mark is also a pretty tantalizing
notion.
Perhaps when the series is finally over, we'll
finally get a chance to see what a cornier,
less-accomplished adaptation of the fantasy
sensation would've looked like.
And we can all cringe right along with the
show's creators at long last.
Until then, we're much like Jon Snow …
"You know nothin', Jon Snow."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!